I took on the challenge to do 20,000
push-ups and pull-ups combined in 30
days I did it for eight days
got hurt now I'm back I'm gonna finish
the job that I started that means every
day doing 34 rounds of 15 push-ups five
pull-ups and ten squats I'm using this
clicker thing to keep track of the
rounds first day 34 done last time
around is one of the toughest things for
me mentally and physically I build up my
base I've lost weight I'm continuing to
lose weight I'm ready for this to hit
hard and to get the job finished it's
gonna take a lot to stop me this time
a lot of people told me I mean you do
numbers like these especially for 30
days you're going to get hurt I don't
care I've been doing sports my whole
life I've wrestled did combat sports my
whole life I weighed lifted my whole
life I've done crazy things athletically
in my whole life I know what I'm doing
that said I know how risky how crazy how
tough this is on the body and yes injury
is a real possibility
in fact on day 3 is when my rachel is
done to develop pain an old familiar
overuse pain that I know well and I kept
pushing I kept pushing and pushing
because pain is one thing injuries
another so I kept really sensing of is
it getting closer and closer to injury
this was the hardest mental challenge
for me is there's times where I had to
lay face down on the carpet just
doubting everything about my life what
am I doing with my life just all the
flood of excuses coming into my head
that the shoulder it was all coming from
the shoulder the shoulder was running in
the body the brain couldn't do anything
with it and I think I'm really proud of
pushing as far as eight days through
that but then I started to feel that
injury is going to become a real
possibility so that's when I took a
break on all the upper body exercises
and started to do the recovery ice and
Bend exercises that I can talk about in
another time every single day and I
still ran six miles every single day
until today today I'm restarting that
challenge I finished the six miles again
and the 34 rounds
fifteen push-ups five pull-ups and ten
squats now this is just some silly
exercises but a lot of people have told
me that I'm going to get injured a lot
of people in my other aspects of my work
have told me that I'm going to burn out
I'm gonna work too hard
those people need to unfollow me that
advice is obvious millions of people
will tell you to do this it's obvious
you should get enough sleep you should
get a healthy moderate dose of exercise
you should have a diet you should have a
balanced life the thing that I need and
I believe the thing that a lot of people
need is not that kind of advice they
need a small number of people around
them to support them to push harder to
work harder to take the risks the quote
unquote dumb thing to take the risk of
injury to take the risk of burnout in
the name of passion in the name of
discovering something about yourself
that's why I took on this challenge
that's why I'm talking to the crazy
David Goggins not because I'm trying to
establish a healthy lifestyle but
because I'm trying to discover something
about myself on the way of establishing
a healthy lifestyle
I believe it's nonzero probability of me
taking and finishing this challenge
that's why I took it on that's why I
kept pushing through the pain to
discover something about myself the kind
of things I need to fix up about the way
I do the exercises but also mentally the
most important things that mentally now
that said I didn't even hit you no David
Goggin talks about the 40% rule I don't
think I even get gotten to like the 5%
for me I am I know how to suffer and
there are things in this life I'm
willing to suffer for they have to do
much more with the things my main
passions in life and work and artificial
intelligence
there's things I'm really willing to put
in the work push-ups and pull-ups is not
one of them at the end of the day I want
to establish a healthy habit where every
single day I'm doing some running is
some bad weight exercises that takes
under an hour that just keeps me healthy
keeps me feeling good keeps me moving
keeps my immune system strong
keeps me feeling great I think there's a
magic to exercise for clearing the mind
for just giving you this vibrant energy
to hit whatever the heck you're working
on in the rest of the day I really think
that people in academic circles and
research circles just engineers in
general need to get their butts out
there and do some exercise I think this
huge amount of value to that even if
it's just walking get 10,000 15,000
20,000 steps a day and he's a huge value
to that I think a long time ago I
decided that I'm going to have to suffer
to reach my goals and one of the things
I learned about myself at least maybe
this applies to others that the ability
to withstand suffering to really
withstand the grind is a kind of muscle
that needs to be trained you really do
need to do something difficult every day
this push up pull up thing is a
representation of that but I do
something difficult every day if you're
following along make sure you do
something that's just a little bit crazy
hey you push the limits do not injure
yourself permanently but do push
yourself to point we learn something
about yourself ignore all the excuses
that your head comes up with for not
doing it get your butt out there every
single day try to get some miles in if
you run or walk or bike or whatever and
try to do some some things for the upper
body some bodyweight exercises there's
zero excuses not to do this in this
pandemic one of the biggest things you
can do for yourself is to get the diet
right to get the exercise right so get
out there good luck
stay healthy stay hard and I'll see you
at the end of this 20,000 crazy push up
on pull-up thing that I promise I'll do
and I'll get the job done no matter what
oh one more thing
I know you're probably somebody out
there it's probably typing how they
didn't sign up to be listening to some
Russian do you talk about some exercises
they want some artificial intelligence
lectures content whatever the heck
that's what I do that's my main passion
but I also exercise I also play music I
also love poetry in literature that's
what you get if you don't like it
unsubscribe it doesn't matter this is me
I'm hoping to share
and be open and real with people in my
journey through this whole thing I
really have enjoyed the the community
that has sprung up around conversations
I've had there's so much love in this
world that just energizes me and
inspires me that's why I do this thing
the exercise is just who I am
it's all part of my life if you don't
like it sorry if you like it
come along subscribe or don't doesn't
matter I love you all
you